no es para nada lo que debería ser esta
temporada en el condado de boulder los
incendios forestales han destruido
cientos de edificios mientras que
decenas de miles de personas evacuaron
las ciudades de louisville y superior al
norte de denver mientras la gente se
apresuraba a salir se produjeron largas
filas
me imagino que esto es lo que pareciera
un ataque nuclear
me siento tan mal por la gente en las
casas de atrás es horrible
es la primera vez que me veo envuelta en
algo así te diré que da mucho miedo es
que las condiciones excepcionalmente
secas y combinadas con fuertes y
variables vientos hicieron que el fuego
se expandiera rápidamente y fuera
impredecible varios de los focos se
originaron por las líneas eléctricas
caídas y las ráfagas hicieron que las
llamas saltarán a lugares inesperados
como este bloque de apartamentos
los funcionarios del condado de boulder
resaltaron que en algunas zonas los
bomberos tuvieron que retirarse
quiere asegurarles que nuestro personal
de bomberos está trabajando tan duro
como puede para salvar estructuras
adicionales y cuando sea seguro hacerlo
comenzaremos el emotivo y doloroso
proceso de evaluar los daños en este
contexto la región enfrenta una sequía
histórica el condado de boulder no ha
visto lluvias significativas desde
mediados del verano afortunadamente el
servicio meteorológico nacional predice
que podrían caer hasta centímetros de
nieve en nochevieja